Okay, one more cache design decision to make,
then we're done!
How should we handle memory writes in the
cache?
Ultimately we'll need update main memory with
the new data, but when should that happen?
The most obvious choice is to perform the
write immediately.
In other words, whenever the CPU sends a write
request to the cache, the cache then performs
the same write to main memory.
This is called "write-through".
That way main memory always has the most up-to-date
value for all locations.
But this can be slow if the CPU has to wait
for a DRAM write access - writes could become
a real bottleneck!
And what if the program is constantly writing
a particular memory location, e.g., updating
the value of a local variable in the current
stack frame?
In the end we only need to write the last
value to main memory.
Writing all the earlier values is waste of
memory bandwidth.
Suppose we let the CPU continue execution
while the cache waits for the write to main
memory to complete - this is called "write-behind".
This will overlap execution of the program
with the slow writes to main memory.
Of course, if there's another cache miss while
the write is still pending, everything will
have to wait at that point until both the
write and subsequent refill read finish, since
the CPU can't proceed until the cache miss
is resolved.
The best strategy is called "write-back" where
the contents of the cache are updated and
the CPU continues execution immediately.
The updated cache value is only written to
main memory when the cache line is chosen
as the replacement line for a cache miss.
This strategy minimizes the number of accesses
to main memory, preserving the memory bandwidth
for other operations.
This is the strategy used by most modern processors.
Write-back is easy to implement.
Returning to our original cache recipe, we
simply eliminate the start of the write to
main memory when there's a write request to
the cache.
We just update the cache contents and leave
it at that.
However, replacing a cache line becomes a
more complex operation, since we can't reuse
the cache line without first writing its contents
back to main memory in case they had been
modified by an earlier write access.
Hmm.
Seems like this does a write-back of all replaced
cache lines whether or not they've been written
to.
We can avoid unnecessary write-backs by adding
another state bit to each cache line: the
"dirty" bit.
The dirty bit is set to 0 when a cache line
is filled during a cache miss.
If a subsequent write operation changes the
data in a cache line, the dirty bit is set
to 1, indicating that value in the cache now
differs from the value in main memory.
When a cache line is selected for replacement,
we only need to write its data back to main
00:0discussion on the size of
the working set of a running program, there
are a certain number of separate regions we
need to accommodate to achieve a high hit
ratio: program, stack, data, etc.
So we need to ensure there are a sufficient
number of blocks to hold the different addresses
in the working set.
The bottom line is that there is an optimum
block size that minimizes the miss ratio and
increasing the block size past that point
will be counterproductive.
Combining the information in these two graphs,
we can use the formula for AMAT to choose
the block size the gives us the best possible
AMAT.
In modern processors, a common block size
is 64 bytes (16 words).
DM caches do have an Achilles heel.
Consider running the 3-instruction LOOPA code
with the instructions located starting at
word address 1024 and the data starting at
word address 37 where the program is making
alternating accesses to instruction and data,
e.g., a loop of LD instructions.
Assuming a 1024-line DM cache with a block
size of 1, the steady state hit ratio will
be 100% once all six locations have been loaded
into the cache since each location is mapped
to a different cache line.
Now consider the execution of the same program,
but this time the data has been relocated
to start at word address 2048.
Now the instructions and data are competing
for use of the same cache lines.
For example, the first instruction (at address
1024) and the first data word (at address
2048) both map to cache line 0, so only one
them can be in the cache at a time.
So fetching the first instruction fills cache
line 0 with the contents of location 1024,
but then the first data access misses and
then refills cache line 0 with the contents
of location 2048.
The data address is said to "conflict" with
the instruction address.
The next time through the loop, the first
instruction will no longer be in the cache
and it's fetch will cause a cache miss, called
a "conflict miss".
So in the steady state, the cache will never
contain the word requested by the CPU.
This is very unfortunate!
We were hoping to design a memory system that
offered the simple abstraction of a flat,
uniform address space.
But in this example we see that simply changing
a few addresses results in the cache hit ratio
dropping from 100% to 0%.
The programmer will certainly notice her program
running 10 times slower!
So while we like the simplicity of DM caches,
we'll need to make some architectural changes
to avoid the performance problems caused by
conflict misses.-latency access
to recently-accessed blocks
of data.
If the requested
data is in the cache,
we have a “cache hit” and the
data is supplied by the SRAM.
If the requested data
is not in the cache,
we have a “cache miss” and
a block of data containing
the requested location will
have to be moved from DRAM
into the cache.
The locality principle
tells us that we
should expect cache
hits to occur much more
frequently than cache misses.
Modern computer systems
often use multiple levels
of SRAM caches.
The levels closest to the CPU
are smaller but very fast,
while the levels further
away from the CPU
are larger and hence slower.
A miss at one level of the
cache generates an access
to the next level, and so on
until a DRAM access is needed
to satisfy the initial request.
Caching is used in
many applications
to speed up accesses to
frequently-accessed data.
For example, your
browser maintains
a cache of
frequently-accessed web pages
and uses its local
copy of the web page
if it determines the
data is still valid,
avoiding the delay
of transferring
the data over the Internet.
Here’s an example memory
hierarchy that might be found
on a modern computer.
There are three levels
on-chip SRAM caches,
followed by DRAM main memory
and a flash-memory cache
for the hard disk drive.
The compiler is
responsible for deciding
which data values are
kept in the CPU registers
and which values require
the use of LDs and STs.
The 3-level cache
and accesses to DRAM
are managed by circuity
in the memory system.
After that the access
times are long enough
(many hundreds of
instruction times)
that the job of managing
the movement of data
between the lower
levels of the hierarchy
is turned over to software.
Today we’re discussing how
the on-chip caches work.
In Part 3 of the course,
we’ll discuss how the software
manages main memory and
non-volatile storage devices.
Whether managed by
hardware or software,
each layer of the
memory system is
designed to provide
lower-latency access
to frequently-accessed locations
in the next, slower layer.
But, as we’ll see, the
implementation strategies will
be quite different in the
slower layers of the hierarchy.you
know the cache just replaced.
I'm not sure I care about how well a program
designed to get bad performance runs on my
system, but the point is that most replacement
strategies will occasionally cause a particular
program to execute much more slowly than expected.
When all is said and done, an LRU replacement
strategy or a close approximation is a reasonable
choice.